Kami no Gourmet Special
Kyada It's made by mixing egg whites with the main dish.
In order to prevent food from rotting during Hideyoshi's dispatch of troops, it
is said that he used salt
boilers as a countermeasure.
Clear ground bumper green
[music]
Good
Erotic medium armor dish Sauce type
Chevelle In
other words, venison is the main menu meat
Pulp
[Applause] In
the match we witnessed, Tsukasa seniors played deer meat.
At that time, Yukihira didn't stand a chance
at all, but he sent me a descriptive piece saying that he was letting me play with a plate that was higher than that.
Try comparing it to the deer from that time
[music] It's
just a reaction Cream twin and daily
cure  I'm telling you, the
ad appetizer led us to more than just the finale of the course.
Here we are all fish
.